- You're weirder than I ever thought.
- Today me and my wonderful father
are going to be reading
through my Tinder messages.
- You're going to be
reading the first messages
that I've been saying to these girls.
- You are a little dramatic sometimes,
so I don't know what to expect.
- Do you get raunchy?
- We'll see, I don't know.
- (laughs) You're six two, does that mean
you can throw me over your
shoulder and spank my ass?
- Wanna come to church tomorrow?
- They didn't reply to that one.
- Are you Moroccan?
'Cause you're Moroccan my socks off.
Do you like Moroccan girls?
Is that why you asked her?
- I don't think I've
ever met a Moroccan girl.
- Are you getting some S and M?
You're gonna be a lonely old man.
- Love your profile pic,
but I'd love even more to
see what's further down.
Your introductions to people are...
- Netflix and chill or
Korean BBQ and some texts
then mutual ghosting each other?
How's this mutual ghosting?
You just scare each other?
Boo!
- Are you ready for your
yearly prostate exam?
Who taught you this?
- If I could rearrange the alphabet,
I'd put F and ME next to each other.
(Adam laughs)
- Are you butt dialing me because I swear
(Roland laughs)
that ass is calling me.
- In order, how would you rank
each season of "Arrested Development"?
I never understood this
"Arrested Development".
Is that people that...
- Are you a top or a bottom?
In terms of, um, dancing?
- It's kind of like dancing.
- Let's do dinner, and my
dinner I mean each other.
You're gonna each other, what is that?
- No, we're not cannibals.
- Take nude photos of me.
That's actually a little sick.
This is inappropriate, Adam.
I'm surprised at you.
- Are you serious?
Did you not say this
to mom when you guys--
- What, no!
- He's gonna die a lonely
old man all by himself.
- Oh, gosh, Adam.
I'm really blown away by all this.
- It's a little dramatic,
it's a little dramatic, it is.
- Don't show your parents this stuff.
We're gonna have a long talk.
- I'm definitely glad I do
not live at home anymore.
- You might need to move back.
- We might need to see a specialist.
- I reap for the future.
(laughter)